and i'm pleased to say the health
secretary matt hancock
joins us on the program very good
morning to you minister
um you'll know that i have seen the
front pages this morning several of them
i have something of a tone of
triumphalism which i'm sure you're going
to
to back away from but i'm not wrong to
detect a bit of a
spring in your step this morning
well this is this is promising news
but it is one step of many that we need
to take to get out of this
and to tackle this pandemic once and for
all so
i i think it is it is absolutely
reasonable
for people to be to see this as a step
forward
but we've got to know that this is one
step
amongst many that we collectively
need to take and and the critical thing
is that for all your viewers that we all
keep our resolve on the measures that
are in place now
because it still will take some time to
go from
this good news that the fisa vaccine is
around 90
effective um to proving its safety
being able to license it and then the
vast task
which which obviously we've been working
on for some time
of uh of making sure that everybody in
the population can take the
can get the jab as you say it will take
some time to get out there but can we
at least give some rough idea of the
timeline for all of this reports this
morning that
the nhs is on on standby to start
deploying
uh deploying this at some point in
december does that shine with with what
you know
yes i've asked the nhs who have been
supported by the armed
services in this but the nhs is very
much leading
this this effort for deploying the
vaccine i've asked them to be ready from
the start of december
um of course there are many hurdles that
still need to be gone over
and you know we haven't seen the full
safety data and obviously that is
critical and we won't deploy
a vaccine unless we can be confident in
its clinical
safety um but we also do need to be
ready
should a vaccine be licensed
and get through all those hurdles and
and
and ready to roll it out
plenty of people will be hearing that
and cheating at their screens this
morning so i wonder if
as you say that that safety data stacks
up
certainly all the noises from fazer
would appear to suggest that that's the
case
how will this be rolled out who will be
prioritized and
and who frankly won't be
well there's a there's there's an
incredibly important
clinical process of deciding on the
prioritization
and the joint committee on vaccinations
and immunizations which is
the legal statutory body that advises me
as health secretary
on these things and they have done some
very impressive work
working with both pfizer and astrazeneca
who are
responsible for the two leading vaccine
candidates
to understand the appropriate
clinical prioritization and i i just
heard you
on the bulletins describing that i
thought it was very well described
it starts with the most vulnerable who
are people who live in
our care homes and of course the the
staff who
look after them and then nhs
and social care staff and then coming
down
essentially down through the the age
ranges
that prioritization is set
by the this clinical body this uh
joint committee and um we will
take their uh their advice on the best
way to roll this out
to protect people to keep people safe as
soon as possible but it will take some
time
there have to be two doses and then
there has to be a period before somebody
is uh is effectively protected
just in time just one quick question
then in terms of the prioritization i
mean you yourself have
made it clear that being from a minority
ethnic background is a major risk factor
when it comes
to contraction and significant effects
from covert 19 why not prioritize um the
bain community
other people suggesting you know
teachers are essentially frontline
workers as well
should they not be prioritized
yeah so we've looked into these uh
questions the j
the jcvi uh has looked into this
and and um the the key determined that
the central determinant
of the risk that covid faces to you
is your age that is a big has a bigger
impact on your likelihood of dying from
coronavirus than any other
factor and so the the reason for this
prioritization
is to protect the most vulnerable and of
course
at the health and social care staff who
work with those who are most vulnerable
to the disease
uh to further protect them that's not
only the best
approach clinically it's also the best
approach in terms of getting
life back to normal because the faster
we can protect
those who are most at risk the
the easier it will be to be able to have
confidence to be able to take the steps
that it will allow life to get back to
normal
but until that stage until that stage it
is so important
that we hold our resolve and that we all
follow the rules and the social
distancing and the basics of hands-face
space
indeed and one of the reasons that we
are not being
you know that we've been cautious this
morning is that yes this is promising
news but there is
a lot way a long way further to go and
this remains
a deadly disease there was perhaps
less caution shown yesterday lunchtime
when professor john bell
said that we will have life back to
normal by spring i mean straight
question
is that correct well we want to get life
back to normal
as quickly as possible and this is a
this is a good step well i'm not going
to put a date
on it i'm afraid um because there are so
many steps that we still need to
go through in order to get this right
and you know
professors are there to give their
opinion um
and what i'm telling you is the work
that we all have to do
a huge effort from the nhs to
deliver this vaccine should it
be licensed and still all the scientific
steps that are needed so we can have
confidence
in its safety and the work of course on
the
astrazeneca and the other vaccines so
there's an awful lot to do
and in the meantime it is it is crucial
that people keep following the the
social distancing guidance
and you know we've always said that the
strategy is
we suppress the virus protecting the
economy
education and the nhs until a vaccine
can make us safe
that is the government's strategy and
this is a good step forward
in delivering on that strategy uh we
have pre-ordered
at 10 million doses of the of of the
pfizer vaccine as you say
two shots required for every individual
it's my understanding that these 10
million are for across the united
kingdom
so can we put a figure of that 10
million
of those 10 million doses of the vaccine
how many people in
england are you estimating that will be
vaccinated in this
this first tranche
well we have a uh we have an uh an order
uh we've secured 40 million doses in
total
of the of the pfizer vaccine
and that means that we can roll it out
obviously to 20 million people because
it requires
two doses per person
this is why we've been buying across the
board
and the vaccines task force have done a
very good job of buying
six different vaccines because
we need to secure enough for everybody
who
needs one according to that uh clinical
prioritization
and and so um the uh we've we've secured
the 40 million
uh from pfizer the job of the nhs and of
deployment is to be able to deploy it as
quickly as they can manufacture it
because we've talked about the science
and we've talked about the deployment
but we've also there's also
the manufacture of this vaccine these
are not easy things to produce
and it's pfizer who's doing the
manufacture of this one astrazeneca
obviously doing the manufacture of the
oxford vaccine
and and so our our task and the task of
the nhs is to deploy it
as fast as it can be made available
indeed i i understand questions about
timeline are very difficult in the early
stages and given we still don't have the
safety data but but in terms of
you know the rest of us the bulk of the
population
it doesn't look likely that we will be
getting our hands on the vaccine until
some point
well into next year is that correct
well we've always been clear that our
central
expectation for the rollout of a vaccine
should a vaccine come good and even with
this brilliant news
uh last night of course we
um we still have to see that safety data
and that
we still have to be confident that it's
clinically safe even with that news
um the central expectation of the
of the bulk of the rollout and
deployment has always been
in the first part of 2021
and so this is as i say this is a
promising step
but the but that is the the central
expectation of our time scale uh
but um you know if we got uh
bad news it would have been we might
have had to push that back that remains
my central expectation
um just in terms of of course the the
other aspect of our fight back against
uh coronavirus
the test and trace indeed mass testing
uh
and tracing we understand that the
scheme that has been rolled out in
liverpool will be rolled out elsewhere
at suggestion that it could be a
nottinghamshire can can you confirm that
and indeed confirm whether or not
universities are going to be able to be
part of this mass testing scheme
yes the two separate questions yes we're
working with
universities on how students
safely can get home for christmas
and i can confirm that we are
rolling out the the sort of mass testing
that we're seeing
in liverpool and indeed we earlier
piloted in
stoke on trent across 66 different
local authorities and last night i wrote
to the director of public health of all
local authorities in england
saying that we can make available these
these
brilliant new lateral flow tests that
give you the result in 15 minutes
and we can make them available
to director of public health right
across the country
66 expressed an interest in the first
instance
i'm now expecting a whole load more if
you're a director of public health
watching this this morning and
uh you haven't signed up for this yet
then uh please do
let us know and we'll we'll get you on
board and of course across the devolved
nations in fact you asked earlier a
question about the vaccine deployment
that is
absolutely a uk program i'm working
closely with my
counterparts who run the nhs in the
devolve nations
because obviously the nhs will be
deploying this
but it is a it is the uk government has
bought the vaccine for the whole of the
uk and it will be rolled out fairly
across the whole of the uk
with the same prioritization no matter
where you live in this country
and the same goes for mass testing
making sure we roll that out across the
whole uk
mr hancock clearly there are reasons for
optimism this morning and i
certainly don't want to reinforce the
stereotype of the dire scotsman but but
there perhaps is a need to
express a note of caution in all of this
you've already mentioned the problems
when it comes to manufacturing the fires
are vaccine
there are issues around the storage of
it it needs to be kept at temperatures
of
minus 70 degrees celsius which you know
care homes
probably won't have um kate bingham of
course chairman of the vaccine task
force
told us select committee last week you
know we have to find
better vaccine formats than than the
pfizer vaccine
you've been saying all the way through
the interview but i just want you to be
absolutely clear
the fires are vaccine is not the end of
all this is it
no absolutely not um you've described
some of the
enormous complexity of the deployment of
this
of this vaccine and the the the need to
keep it at such a cold temperature is
obviously very
complicated also you can't take it out
of that freezer more than four times on
its journey from
the manufacturing plant into the uh
into the arm of patients um more than
four times so that
brings its complications um i'm sure
that the nhs is going to rise to this
challenge of of deployment and we've
been working on it for
for months now um but um
what i'd say is that this is uh this is
i've said it all this is a promising
step
but there's many steps still to come and
in the same way that this early vaccine
and the astrazeneca
vaccine should its data be uh
be good um they are important
important contributions to dealing with
this
pandemic but there's much more work to
come
i i know minister you have a busy day
and i i'm keeping you over your time but
one very quick question
at the oxford vaccine you yourself have
mentioned it are we expecting to hear
from
from them next week
uh we don't know exactly when and the
the timings of these rollout uh
these publications are determined by the
science
not by some administrative decision
because it's when
you could be clinically confident in the
in the result of the
clinical trial uh that then the
uh the those responsible are duty-bound
immediately to
uh to come forward with the uh with the
news
so there are very clear rules around the
timing of results from clinical trials
they're not determined by
uh by by government ministers or indeed
by the execs of the companies involved
they're determined by the science
so we're not exactly sure when further
news will come
from the from the from the oxford trial
but um but we're working
again to ensure that that can be
deployed
should it come off